der Betrug die Schwindelei oder sagen
wir es modern das Framing im
Zusammenhang mit der deutschen
Wirtschaft oder mit der Wirtschaft
überhaupt eins habe ich schon erwähnt
den Begriff Sondervermögen man schafft
Geld dass es nicht gibt und nennt es
vermögen normalerweise war das ein Fall
für eine Generalstaatsanwaltschaft wie
bei den cum-ex-geschichten in dem Fall
nicht das zweite ist unser fette
Wirtschaftsminister Habeck hat jetzt
angekündigt wir hätten eigentlich keine
Rezession die ist zwei Quartale
hintereinander gibt es eine technische
Rezession das bedeutet irgendwie ist sie
nicht wirklich das ist keine es gibt
keine technische Rezension man kann auch
nicht sagen es gibt eine technische
Schwangerschaft wir sprechen aber nicht
vom technischen Krankheiten wenn einer
nur Heuschnupfen hat das gibt es doch
alles nicht ein anderes Betrug und jetzt
wo sie uns mit voller härter erwischt
kommt Frau lagard und sagt in den
letzten 25 Jahren das noch prima
gelaufen nennen sie das anders als
Betrug das doch Augenwischer